okay Three Stooges was directed by the
Farrelly Brothers now you know them from
movies like Dumb and Dumber or there's
something about meri stuck on you stars
these guys who play The Three Stooges
and really the only one I recognize is
Sean Hayes I believe is his name and he
was on the show Will and Grace
it also has Jane Lynch as well as Larry
David and Jennifer Hudson and it's a
story of The Three Stooges these guys
were raised on an orphanage they were
dropped there when they were young no
one ever wanted them no one ever picked
him up and they cause problems for the
orphanage they were terrible they broke
everything it cuts them being older and
they're still there they're unwanted and
now they find out that the orphanage is
going to be closed down because it
doesn't have the money to pay for
certain things it needs to do so they go
into the big city to experience an
adventure and hopefully entertain us
with laughs now before I get into my
review let me just say that my dad's a
huge fan of The Three Stooges TV show
I've seen many episodes of The Three
Stooges TV show I'm fully aware of the
type of humans in that show and how
classic it is and how it works very well
in its time it was funny they were
pioneers in regards to slapstick humor
however this is one of the worst
comedies I've ever seen I literally did
not laugh one time in this movie never
once did I laugh throughout this entire
film I legitimately would have laughed
if something funny happen in this movie
this is the most unfunny comedy I have
seen in years it just tries to copy the
exact same humor and routines that were
in that TV show for today and try to
make it appealing to like a young
audience by putting Jersey Shore in
there by having Moga cast on Jersey
Shore and their Snooki in a situation
and everything it's a giant way to try
to get young audiences interested in
something that was old it is so clearly
obvious they're trying to invigorate the
Three Stooges into some kind of current
pop culture trend to try to get young
people to like it when the movie ended I
looked over my friend and I was like
tell me what you thought of that movie
and he goes I'll never get that hour and
a half back and I was like thank you if
you would have said you liked that movie
I don't know what I would have done this
movie started out it was going to be
with Jim Carrey and Sean Penn and be
Nancy O'Dell Tora but that's how you say
his name and all these actors were so
interested in this movie Jim Carrey even
started gaining weight for his role and
they just dropped out of it because of
money problems and problems of the movie
I don't blame them man this would have
been a career-low point for all of them
there's literally not one thing in this
movie that I can possibly recommend this
is for sure the worst movie I've seen
all year I mean there there's nothing in
it there's there's nothing in this movie
that's good
Jane Lynch is a very funny woman
completely wasted here she literally
does not even crack one joke in this
movie there is not one joke from her
character in this movie she's just there
to be a nun to propel the story along in
some kind of way Larry David plays a nun
okay now that sounds funny Larry David
crater Seinfeld funny guy Curb Your
Enthusiasm funny guy what is he doing in
this movie it's terrible movie I was
sitting there watching it just in awe
like when the movie and I'm not going to
spoil anything but when the movie ended
my jaw actually dropped I would like to
say that there is something in this
movie recommendable but there's not
there literally is not one thing about
this movie I like there was not one
redeeming quality to it you just go to
this movie and you're sitting there in
shock and the fact that thousands of
people got together and thought this
would be a good idea the three stooges
is one of the worst comedies I've seen
in years it was completely unfunny and I
did not laugh once and for sure gets my
lowest grade a big huge fat F don't see
it if you're a fan of the show don't
give this movie money saying they did a
good job because they did not it
disgraces that show don't watch it uh-uh
until next time guys if you liked this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes
Oh